(bright music)
- When I think about the
wilderness of Denali,
I think of vastness and how small we are
in that great big wintry world.
(dog howls)
Sled dogs are not the
National Park Service's idea,
this is an idea that we have
adopted from everyone else
who knew that dog teams
were just the best,
most reliable, and I'd
argue most fun way to travel
around Alaska in winter.
So I'm the kennels manager
in Denali National Park
and Preserve, and I'm
in charge of the only
sled dog kennel in the
entire National Park Service.
In 1980, the original park
boundary was designated
as wilderness, and
officially-designated wilderness
is the highest level of federal
land protection available.
And it means that you can't use any motorized
form of transport to travel.
(dogs bark)
It's all gonna be through
non-motorized transport
so dog teams, skis,
snowshoes, anything like that.
Let me see your teeth.
These dogs are all Alaskan Huskies.
Born and raised for
thousands of years to live in
the harsh winter conditions
of Alaska and to want to run
and pull a sled.
Ready?
Hike!
Asking me my favorite dog
is like asking a parent
their favorite child.
(laughs)
It's not possible to answer that question.
They all win my heart
in some way or another.
These guys are amazing; they
bridge the gap to the wild.
I think the dogs are just
an incredible invitation
and inspiration for our visitors.
We're all a part of this
wilderness, we're all
a part of this place, and
it has so much to offer us
if we're willing to go out and
be challenged by it a little,
to immerse ourselves in it.
(dog barks)